[Music]
so so let's talk about different types
of high standards
right yes like could you elaborate on
tony's particular species of high
standards and if you have any funny
stories that's always great but
you know any any stories that come to
mind are also super helpful and just so
you know where this is going i i'm
wondering like how it contrasts with say
a michael mann or
and i know you i don't think you've had
experience with like james cameron but
like james cameron another person is
really famous for having extremely high
standards
and
you know where the line is between being
like brutally direct
and turning into something else do you
know what i mean yeah i do uh i'd love
to explore that because this is
something i struggle with also so
speaking at the very high end who's
speaking about the michael mann's the
james cameron's the level of expectation
is is
never achievable they will never
it's never good enough
they do not have a level where it's good
enough it can always be better
you have to be that way yes they are
[ __ ] i will say it straight up
michael mann is an [ __ ] and he's
known that way in the industry
but he has to be
that is the only way that you get that
caliber of project done you want to get
through a titanic you are going to have
to be an [ __ ] 100 yeah and the same
is true in in high caliber kitchens
you want to run you want to run a high
caliber kitchen there is only one way to
do it and you are not friends with your
crew
you are you are in charge and it's your
responsibility and and i think that tony
tony approached it from that
from that perspective
at least initially
he had extremely high expectations that
i think were based on his history of
knowing how to run an effective kitchen
and at the same time
he had all kinds of his own like you
know neuroses and stuff that bled into
that and you see it in road runner i
actually one of the parts i really liked
was when
he talks about
hey i'm not going to stop for the
cameras
you guys learn how to get fast
you get fast i do what i do yeah and
that was i loved because he's like
because i could do it i was fast and i
loved working fast like that so yeah
super high standards with tony though
different than
michael and james cameron and i and i
have not worked with james cameron i
know a number of people who have though
i don't think you're ever going to get
that moment with
with michael or with someone like
michael mann or someone like james
cameron where you're like
sitting down and like drinking beers
with them out in the desert and talking
about like life and things that really
mean something and like with tony you
did and that was the difference he was
actually he was a friend and
and a very very important friend you
know
who i miss every single day
he was not
those guys
he wasn't an [ __ ] he could be an
[ __ ] you know he could be an [ __ ]
all the time he could be incredibly
frustrating to work with
but he but there was something under it
there was something very loving there
there was something very caring and once
you were kind of
in
his sphere he really he really did care
about people
so from that perspective it was
different from the work perspective
though he wasn't gonna mince words in
the same way that he wasn't gonna mince
words
when a dish isn't right
in the kitchen like you can't
it doesn't work that way
unless you want 20 [ __ ] risottos sent
back you better get the first one right
and when someone [ __ ] it up you better
let them know that they [ __ ] it up big
time right now immediately and correct
the problem
and that was a lot of the process with
tony in post for sure in the field it
was more like things that were
cumbersome or inconvenienced tony he
didn't like messiness he didn't like
sitting around and like you know that
when [ __ ] goes south on a crew i mean my
god we just look like a bunch of look
like a bunch of chickens with our heads
cut off running around trying to make
[ __ ] happen or trying to make [ __ ] work
and there's a lot of reasons that that
can happen you know he didn't like any
of that and you'd hear about unfucking
yourself quite a bit in those moments
but when it came to posts like
that's a much more calculated thing yeah
and like i would send him rough cuts and
everyone has been through this
i would send him rough cuts where he i
mean from the very beginning he's like
what
possible
reason do you have for presenting me
with this piece of garbage i didn't work
so hard dot dot
in full caps you didn't work so hard
to have your work flush down the toilet
by this [ __ ] editor
you know and you're like oh
okay
are we gonna like are we gonna go in a
constructive direction like what do you
you know
and
but he would and and and that's that was
the thing about him is that
the good ones are right you know
michael mann as much of an [ __ ] as he
was to people
you'd have to kind of be like well he's
right though you know that's right he
knows and he's right he's not wrong with
tony
also
90 of the time he was he was right
and it wasn't up to it wasn't up to the
standards
what was cool about tony is that then he
would he would go on and work the
material
you would start
reforming it you'd start working with
him he'd give constructive
notes and that's something that i tell
people or try to like
explain to people and i think that
people should know about him and
something i do you know kind of wish
they had said in road runner two it's
like
he's
tony was a you go on his wikipedia and
it's like celebrity chef and it's like
yeah that's not how i think of him no
and he wasn't that great of a chef
it's also just that label doesn't i i
didn't know him at all but
the label doesn't make any sense yeah it
sounds so hollow to me given the breadth
of what he did also right 100
to me what he was more than anything
else within my sphere of working with
him was he was a
absolutely
incredible television producer and he
understood story he understood story
structure he understood cinematography
he understood using the tools of film to
make something that was cinematic even
though we were on you know making our
little show on tv it was like it always
wanted to be a feature film and so we
were using like
our limited resources to get as close to
that benchmark as possible
it should look beautiful the framing
should be great the lighting should be
great you know the music needs to be
great
the editing the pace the build up the
way that you present subjects you know
all of that stuff needs to be at the
highest level and that's what people are
seeing i i think when they respond to
the show and the kind of response that
the show has gotten which is really
incredible they're seeing a couple
things authenticity because we never did
[ __ ] twice we never faked anything
that's all real everything you see is
real we didn't set up shots we didn't
call cut we didn't call action we got
fast
we did what he told us today we got fast
you see authenticity and you see just a
very very high level of
production value
given our resources and i think it's
something that
something that i
constantly want to point out to people
is like
look at the weight classes that we were
punching in we were way out of our group
you know i got we're going out on shows
where we're shooting for seven days in
the field
we had we had a three thousand dollar
external equipment rental budget
and we're getting cinematography
nominations my last cinematography
nomination was up against free solo it
was up against free solo
we're punching way out of our class and
that was because of the very high
standards then that can only come from
the top yeah
we were down with it because over the
time he was powerful enough and the the
show was magnetic enough to pull in
people who were very talented who were
gifted who
really wanted to do like good work and
push the genre as far as they could
but that comes from the top and that was
that was tony and that was that's what
you get from that impeccable nature of
like no everything needs to be good
and also you just tony was so [ __ ]
cool that
you really wanted to please him on my
wall i have framed
the best email i ever got from him
that was when i sent him the first act
of the nigeria show
that we shot in legos and it just says
out [ __ ] standing with two
exclamation points and then under it
says couldn't be happier
and i framed it and i put it on my wall
that is so cool
maybe that tells you a little bit i mean
that's like the highest moment of my
career so
you